Hello everybody and welcome to Udacity's Explorers
this week on Human-Robot Interaction and Robot Ethics.
I'm here with the director of Silicon Valley Robotics. Andra Keay. Andra how are you?
I'm great. Good to be here.
Can you tell me a little bit about how you got started in robotics?
I've always been a tech geek but I went through
a few different pathways before coming back to robotics and I say coming back to it,
I actually did film in television technologies and
then computer and Internet technologies and I felt that I was being behind the curve.
So I thought what really is the technology
that is going to be the biggest influence on the 21st century?
And how do I make sure that that's the technology that I'm involved with?
So I went back to study robots and
particularly the areas around how robots are
going to- how are they going to affect society.
So I call it not just human-robot interaction but human-robot culture.
So the idea of like cobots and things like that as well just
kind of everything working together in a nice.
Definitely looking at how things work together.
But going beyond how robots may work with us
as individuals and starting to ask the questions like,
"Will all taxi drivers be out of jobs if we have self-driving vehicles?
Is that a fact,
or will there be slower transitions?
What does it mean if we make a change quickly versus as we make a change in stages?"
And perhaps some of the things are, you know,
where do we make big wrong assumptions about what a technology impact
will be and how can we make better assumptions at
predictions around what the impacts of technologies will be because I think most of
the headlines that you hear or read are completely wrong.
And in fact one of my favorite sayings is a Moore's Law which is that we greatly
overestimate the short term impact of
the technology but we vastly underestimate the long term impact.
And I see robotics and the AI that's embodied in robotics as
being fundamentally transformative technologies of the 21st century,
but I think we get really confused over what are the short term and long term impacts.
So, when you talk about human-robot interaction.
It's not so much just a robot that has
a face that kind of walks around and talks to people.
It's much more than that right?
I mean you're talking about taxicabs and driverless cars.
It's really the idea of any type of interaction with a robot from a human perspective.
Absolutely. And you raised one of those issues- robot systems and I think
that a lot of HRI has focused very
much on psychological studies of what happens between one robot and one person.
But if you look at commercialization and my role with
Silicon Valley robotics has been to help with the commercialization of
a lot of robotics startups and of course you're trying
to increase the spread of a technology.
So you're not ever really in
a situation of talking about one robot, one person interactions.
You're talking about multi-interactions- multiple robots,
multiple people and you're talking about things that need to include duration as well.
So I felt that HRI is great as far as it goes.
But for people to consider that is the only way to look at how
are we going to interact with robots is really missing
many of the other dimensions and durations.
You know there's very little funding for things like a long term study.
So there was one particular one that studied people's feelings about reimbursed
in their life over a period of weeks rather than the one off kind of interaction.
And when you did that it completely
overturned a lot of the papers that were saying people
respond this way to robots that do this and people respond that way to robots to do that.
And I thought, to me that captured exactly where we're going wrong is we take
these little snapshots and we think that it's giving us a full panorama and it's not.
That's common in a lot of studies that you see actually right.
There's always- you're digging in to try to find that one area
but you're not really taking the whole perspective of actually what's going on.
So you shoot in that area and you say,
"Ah this is the exact result that I was looking for,
I set up the study in such a way that I kind of
forced my hand to be able to get something like that."
But the reality is like in the grand scheme of things or
a longer term study you'll realize that it's actually quite the opposite.
Well, I think robotics is very flawed in not being a science.
It's an engineering discipline.
And most papers are not reproducible.
And I'm talking well beyond HRI.
It's really every area.
This was one of the things that Willow Garage
was very strongly about changing that paradigm
by creating a common robotics platform and then a common robotics operating system.
So you had a greater chance of being able to take
somebody else's research and replicate it and ideally get the same results.
And that's been pretty much lacking in the field of robotics.
And for those people who don't know Willow Garage,
he is also the creators of ROS which is why they use the platform for
pretty much any robotics company that's starting within the last 10 years or so.
Absolutely. It's now I think in the last five years,
it's gone from being used by companies that knew
Willow Garage to being used by pretty much every startup that I'm in contact with.
And it may not be being used at
their commercial release level but
it's being used in the development stages at the very least.
So kind of going back to the idea of HRI.
What do you consider in your opinion,
what makes a good robot that interacts with a human?
I think that one of the key things is don't overspecialize,
don't over adorn, don't make
your robot really promise more than it's going to be able to deliver
because I think we still have very very rudimentary abilities
to behave appropriately in context.
And as long as you can't really rely on a robot to know enough about a situation,
to have anything approaching a human level of response,
then creating something that gives us
the expectation is going to- you know it's
going to turn around and bite us because people will be disappointed in that robot.
And we're at a weird point right now where there are a lot of claims.
It's probably easier to sell a robot if you make a lot of promises about what it can do.
And people love the idea of robots that they can
have some sort of relationship in a very broad sense;
companionship, it's cute, something like that but it makes it easier to sell the robot.
But we haven't really had enough robots out there for people to start
to see how well they remain engaged.
And I think most good robotics companies
are actually less concerned with selling the robot
and more concerned with building something that is going to
keep engagement once it has been sold,
once it's in someone's house.
How do you keep people interacting with it.
So it's an interesting idea talking about the engagement level of a robot.
Do you feel that there are certain types of robots
that warrant a higher level of engagement?
And like a stronger bond between people,
so for instance, you know,
government contractors I used to work in
ground stations for UAVs and things like that but I read an article
that one of the soldiers had a UAV that he
flew on a bunch of different missions in Afghanistan or Iraq,
and it was I think 15 missiles or something like that and it got shot down finally.
And when it got shot down,
the soldier demanded a burial for his UAV and they were like, "It's just a robot."
And he was like this thing has saved my life so many times, you know,
with all the landmines ideas and everything else out there he's like,
"I want this thing buried, I want to have a proper sendoff for it."
Do you think you're going to see that kind of reaction from more people kind of
coming forward in the future with like social robots or home robots.
Or do you think it's just going to be kind of one of those- it's kind of a cool thing?
I interact with a little bit,
but then after a while this new and shininess of it kind of wears
off and we actually go back to treatment more like machine?
I think it really depends on the depth of the interaction,
and you've talked about what's really an extreme use case.
It's been engaged in life in death situations.
So you will have a very strong bond.
If it's vacuuming your floors you won't.
And one of the points that has been raised that I think was very
interesting was to suggest that up until this moment in time,
humans really had only a couple of ontological states that we could comprehend.
One was alive and one was dead or inanimate.
So you were either an object or you were an organism and it's saying,
so do we then get into a kind of switch-like state of having things that behave or that
we treat like organisms that then behave like objects and
do we then treat them like objects or do we carry over that more emotional response?
And what does that mean in terms of us developing perhaps empathy,
is one of the biggest worries that people have.
If we are engaging with something that looks like it's alive but we can treat it badly,
is this going to create a lack of empathy in us?
One of the interesting hypotheses is that we're going to
evolve towards a third ontological awareness.
That there are some things that are both alive and not alive that they can be emotionally
engaging but they can be turned off and on at will without damage.
So if we can really develop that third ontological awareness,
then perhaps there is not an issue with us
being trained into a lack of empathy because we
all understand that it's a that thing as opposed to an it or a you.
So it's an interesting idea.
Right. When you started talking about,
it can interact with a person and the person can relate
to it but we can always turn off a switch.
When you're dealing with something like
that is there ever a point where you start looking at it
from the other perspective of like "wow this thing
actually has feelings and emotions right."
So we've seen videos I'm sure you've seen them as well,
Boston Dynamics is a big dog where people have, you know,
the engineers have shown kicking this robot right. Having that scuffle to kind of...
Generally most people go,
"Oh oh!" When they see that.
Exactly.
It encourages that.
However, one of the things I've also seen is that people that are more familiar with
robots don't have quite that shocked pity feeling.
So they've become much more used to what
they're seeing and they will have a different level of response.
And I think it comes back down to saying you
know don't confuse the snapshot for the whole picture.
I've got five what I call
laws of robotics because we all love
Asimov's laws of robotics even though they don't work.
They're never going to work.
And even though I think laws is really the wrong terminology to use,
I think to be effective,
laws kind of come later.
What we really want to be talking about is design guidelines,
suggestions that can educate and inform
people towards better decisions at the earliest possible stages of building robots.
But I call them five laws of robotics and they start really at
the most critical level in terms of Maslow's Hierarchy of Needs which is,
"Don't build killing machines."
And while drones in warfare maybe they are currently
accepted but they're a bit of a mix.
They're informational.
They can do other things.
They're not necessarily weapons.
I think the key concept there is if you build something that is nothing but
a killing machine then it's very difficult to have some other purpose for it.
So the key principle is always build a multipurpose robot.
Not something that is purely evil.
And then the next one down is build things that obey laws and it might seem obvious
but there isn't really clear areas like does this robot breach privacy law?
And are you aware of what privacy laws in different countries is?
So when you're putting sensors onto something,
are they going to be law abiding or not?
And we do start to run into issues where you have a lot of
senses required for autonomous vehicles for
mobile robots and they're going to start to be traveling in areas
where they can be unpredicted data breaches,
privacy breaches, surveillance issues.
So can you think through these things ahead of time?
Those laws exist because there is a social standard that we've come to agree on.
So you have to inform yourself as to why they exist and how what
you build might end up putting you on the wrong side of those things.
Ultimately, the other laws relate
to building things that don't create the wrong expectation.
So build a robot system that is as transparent as
possible so that you understand as much as possible about
what its intentions are and what its capabilities are.
What it is able to do? And for me that is you know don't
be deceptive and don't build deceptive robots.
A robot that's humanoid is going to create
the impression in us that it is capable of humanoid level behaviors.
And the reality is that it's not you know but we're going to
think that it can remember us from time to time.
We're going to think that if it uses
emotional hand gestures that it's going to be able to understand our emotional state,
that it will understand things like proximity and body space.
So you get into a lot of trouble because at
the moment we don't really have that level of understanding or intelligence.
So I think that there are reasons for building robots
that can have a good social interaction but at
the moment I think you need to keep them in a very narrow domain so
that you don't start to imagine you've got a general purpose friend.
Know what you have is a very helpful assistant driver or a very helpful medicine cabinet.
You don't have a friend or something else
and within that there are also other areas around transparency which relate to,
is it possible for other people to understand how something is
making its decisions and how it's operating which comes
down to you know algorithmic transparency as well,
where incorporating a lot of black boxes into what we do.
And I know that's probably a problem that you've covered elsewhere.
So ultimately from that is avoid black boxes and avoid overfeaturing a robot,
you know, don't be humanoid if you don't need to be.
Some of the best robots ones like say,
Mayfield's robotics Kuri, it doesn't have a screen,
it doesn't have a lot of features,
it acts more like a toy than a humanoid.
It makes sure that you can appreciate
its limits much more and I think also Catalia Health's Mabu.
And that's something that I see in the best robot designs.
They focus on, can you do what you do well rather than trying to do everything.
And ultimately there's one final guideline
is can we tell who is responsible for robots? Who owns it?
Do we have any kind of idea about registration,
license plates for robots or something else like that
because you are definitely already seeing robots in public places.
In the Westfield shopping malls for example,
in the streets of Redwood City delivering food,
in San Francisco streets;
San Jose, San Jose Airport.
Now who is having that interaction with you?
Right. Is it the robot or is it you know the person who's programmer of that?
Well, the robots at the front of that.
But is that an interaction on behalf of San Jose airport or is it
an interaction on behalf of a third party who is using the space at San Jose Airport.
Who do you contact if that robot runs over your toddler's toes.
OK. All of these things but the physical potential harm and
the economic and emotional potential harm that can happen in these situations.
You need to be able to say,
"Who's robot is that?"
And I foresee a time coming up very soon where we have
a lot of robots engaged in advertising and sales not just delivery.
And as such it's not hard to create
something that gives us the illusion of- that can capture our attention.
OK. You know a billboard even if it's
a moving billboard it's looking to capture our attention anywhere near as much
as a humanoid object that can also use some movement and some other visual cues
to capture our attention because ultimately we're still
chimpanzees in terms of of our responses.
There are certain things that will trigger our responses.
Then what is the purpose?
The robot is probably there to be conducting business of some kind.
And are you going to be as
informed and as in charge of that relationship as you would be if
it was a person saying would you like to have a free sample of
this and would you like to come into the shop and try this on.
Or all of those other things that we're used to humans saying and we're used
to ignoring or we're used to being out to assess who they are?
What they're doing and why they're doing it?
So that for me is the last area of real transparency where
the license plates and where's the chain of
responsibility and how do we have access to it.
So talking about the interaction that you're having with some of
these robots do you feel that the human biases of the people who
are building design of these robots are actually
impacting the kind of interaction we're having with it on the other end?
Yeah, I think initially we had robots that were being built to the- how would you say,
to the biases and desires and imagination of the robot builders.
And also the limitations of
the form factor around certain things so some robots came out looking
female simply because you needed to have a wider hip base to
incorporate whatever the mechanisms being used
were and other robots came out looking something different.
So we started off with
purely physical mechanical limitations but then they became creatures of the imagination.
And what's worrisome is that that starts to perpetuate biases and stereotypes.
Now just as quickly as people start
to become more informed and be looking at good design,
I think we also have a negative pressure from businesses who can
already quantify our responses to
merchandising and start to use certain genders,
voices and appearances based on what
they've assessed is going to give us the most accurate and the...
The best trigger if you will.
Yeah the best trigger.
Exactly. And one of the things that someone's brought up is you
know where are the black robots.
So you already have a lack of representation
but I think the lack of representation is going to continue in really bad ways.
Someone has expressed it really nicely and they've said
that stereotypes are not a problem because they're false.
They're a problem because they're only one of the truths.
And whenever you use the stereotype you ignore all of the other truths.
And so when we use those stereotype robots we're
forcing a convergence on a very narrow set of
representations that may be true and may be effective.
But we're going to do away with having any of the other true representations.
It'll be very off putting for a lot of people
too if you're not in that target demographic.
You're going to feel like I don't relate,
I don't like the way that this thing is you know portraying itself to me.
It's very off putting too. Right.
We're going to see some very clear things around
say one of the things that I've been tracking is the use of
gendered stereotypes in work positions so kiosk robots tending to being female,
assistant robots female, authoritative robots male.
Now how do women break through the glass ceiling if we are
creating a robotically amplified world in which women
are the assistance and service providers rather than
the executives or leaders or people with the voice of authority.
This will be sending us a few steps backwards and we won't even see it coming.
Yeah it's a really interesting concept right.
When you hear people of genderising they're robots
because you see it from time to time where someone will say,
"Well, he's a good robot or she's a good robot."
And I never quite understood why you
would do something like that because really getting into the data,
the robot is not a person.
Like the robot has no feelings,
the robot is just algorithms and
sensors that are meant to work together to provide some sort of an experience,
whatever that may be.
So I prefer to call robot an it or that or they. What would you call it?
Yeah absolutely. I try very hard to always call them it.
I actually think that we should go ahead and develop a third set of
pronouns similar to that third ontological awareness out of respect for what they are.
And also to help us see them as
the artificial embodied intelligences that a robot is.
So I think we should first off this comes to overfeaturing a robot.
Anything that adds trappings of gender should not be there.
I really believe that we can create non-gendered asexual robots and we
can utilize a new way of referring to them
and that ultimately would be the safest thing for us as a society.
Looking at some of the robots and the interactions that we have with them right now.
Right. There's a lot of robots that you're starting to see move into factories right.
There were the factories that we had of the past which were basically
just gigantic robot arms and no humans were interacting.
But now we're starting to see you know other companies like we think
robotics is a great example right with their backs their robot
where they're kind of showing hey this robot you know coexist in
works alongside a human in a certain environment.
It seems like that reaction is kind of mixed from a lot of
people in these factories where it's like it's great that this robot is helping me out.
But how long before this robot credit comes over and takes over my job.
Do you think that we're going to get to a point where
humans are going to be replaced by robots and factories altogether
or do you think there's always going to be some level of existence of coexistence
with a human and a robot in a factory working together?
I believe that robots are always going to augment us rather than replace us.
And I think at the moment the best thing to do is to say that robots take tasks not jobs.
But I would like to see factories that don't have people in them.
I think it's an inhuman job.
It is the epitome of robotic labor.
You know I don't believe that that is a job that feeds human need for
social interaction or creativity or any of the things that we like.
I think if people didn't need
the money they wouldn't voluntarily go to work in a factory.
And I think we have an opportunity to look at our world, our life,
our economy, our society,
and say we have an opportunity to remake everything.
What are the things that people shouldn't be doing and they should not be doing
a lot of the dull dirty dangerous jobs and it's one of
the most striking arguments for autonomous vehicles
is to reduce death on the roads you know
automobile accidents are one of
the greatest costs for- of human lives in in most societies these days.
So that's definitely a reason to look at having
autonomous vehicles which will have
a much better safety record
as long as we've got them to the point where they are definitely going to have.
And I think you need to be at
a much greater safety level than a human behind the wheel because
we accept a certain amount of risk from human behavior.
We will not accept that exact same amount of risk from robot behavior.
Robots have to be significantly I think an order of magnitude
better before we're going to want to wholesale adopt them into certain areas.
But we shouldn't be mining underground directly.
That's one of the most deadly jobs imaginable going into space is also deadly.
I mean I definitely want to go to Mars but I
don't want to spend unneeded amounts of time in space
preparing habitats and building rockets and doing
things that have huge exposure to radiation.
So I think there's a whole class of jobs that we ought
to automate completely as fast as possible.
But every single robot that's out there needs to be built.
It needs to be programmed and it needs to be managed.
And I think we're going to have a huge class of employment that
relates to looking after and training robots and it's
going to range from the highly skilled you know
more algorithmic jobs down to ones that are much more physical like oh it's
missed plugging itself in down on aisle four
let's go and walk along and make sure that they've all got good contacts to charge up.
And while we're at it let's you know tidy that
one up and we're slated to do routine maintenance.
You know let's do these kind of things.
You know I see robots and looking after robots.
In many ways take the place that the automobile has had over the last century.
So we've seen one transition where a huge chunk of
human society used to be involved in looking after
horses and then they transitioned to looking after automobiles.
And I think there's going to be another transition to looking after the broader range.
Let's say I call a car a robot,
and it's just going to be many more and different.
Do you think there just be more specialized in the sensitives,
so let's say if you have a mechanic now you might have somebody who works on
biped robots only or somebody who works on air vehicles only,
do you think that's going to be kind of like the emergence of
new jobs like well you're trained technically to
do kind of all of them but you're really going to be focused on
one area or one brand or one manufacturer?
Oh, definitely you are going to have really infinite scope for
specialization and ideally it won't be manufacturing
specific because I think one of the things holding robotics
back is a lack of some of
the common standards and platforms that you're going to need to have.
So you know we see this in very small scale with
the importance of ROS and with things like the importance of
a common standard for in defect on the end robot arms.
So it doesn't really matter whether it's a Phantogram,
a cougar arm or a universe robotics arm or a Sawyer from wreathing robotics.
Those range of end effectors will all be able to be used on it.
But where are some of the other things that we're still developing
perhaps multi robot communication protocols and so forth.
Ye, s maybe just using the Internet but what about in other situations.
I think we're going to see more common standards emerge, we'll have to.
But I think your specification will relate to form
factor and will relate to industries so let's say
a biped robot that does something on farms is going to be
a vastly different biped robot to one that is doing something in clothing stores.
Sure.
So, I also think that there's a huge scope for creative employments.
One of the jobs that you do with social robotics is write scripts and you know look at...
Catalia Health as a great example of
that half their staff as basically writers and psychologists.
Yes. And companies like Anki,
many of the others half of this stuff are game designers and visual illustrators.
And I think also people who are
dance and theater people because you're having to teach and create.
The appropriate behaviors in whatever the narrow area
is then you have to have domain expertise who understand you know what is
important in a robot that has an interaction with you for the purposes of understanding
your health needs and how different is that to
a robot that is going to interact with you in a clothing store.
And it's highly specialized but completely
different modes of behavior and background knowledge required.
But we underestimate the sheer physical.
I mean robots if anyone can
remember the very early days of the automobile and I personally can't,
but they were all a little different and they all didn't work most of the time.
More or less.
So just physically looking after them.
Sometimes the biggest thing we forget when we talk about robots entering the world is
that they're going to be physical and it might be like I said
as simple as putting it back on to charge properly.
It might be moving something out of the way because it stopped working and
maybe there is something blocking it so you can't tell he operated out of the way.
There's going to be a heap of teleoperation
and one of the big ways in which I think we need to
interact with- where robots and humans will work
together has to do with that remote operation.
So I see a future where the robot can
tell you where to find things on aisle four and offer to show you the way.
But when you ask it if they think that this brand
is better than that brand that immediately goes to the human operator...
Right because with a robot when you use a product,
let's say a shampoo or something like that.
They can say, "Why would you want...?"
Or necessarily have the ability to ask the right questions to understand who is it for?
What is the this or
perhaps just the trust level that we would have from an interaction with the person.
DARPA has modified Dragon-Fly to put on
a backpack onto this insect which basically controls
its nervous systems so they can actually monitor and move the actual
biological being in the way that they choose.
Is this something that we should be kind of playing around with still?
Or is this something that at this point in
our technology that we feel like you know what we really don't need
as many biologically created animals as possible we really should start
focusing more on just purely robots
or is this kind of like a necessary hurdle that we have to get over?
I mean we see a lot with animal testing with makeup products and things like that
but from a robot perspective it might be slightly concerning.
Right because you're starting to say well we're just going to hijack this host and
we're going to have this host do whatever we want it to do even though
it's own physical being or entity of some form.
There was a lot of outcry over the crowd from campaign for you know do it yourself
mouse or rat brain hacking chips or cockroach.
Cockroach hacking. There are several interesting ethical dilemmas and elements in there.
When I see the fruits of this research being
used to allow someone to use an embedded chip to
move a prosthetic arm when they've had no movement then I think it's a good thing
especially when I put it into the context of
realizing that we still do incredible amount of research on animals.
For cosmetics as you said for reasons that seem far less compelling but
we kill a lot of animals and we torture a lot of animals for many reasons already.
What's the real difference between putting chips in and remote controlling them.
But it raises a couple of issues.
One is what's the end goal of this?
And I think the reality is we're starting to produce some very small flying robots.
No where near as fuel efficient as
your average insect bird but we're improving technologies
all the time so I think you can see a future
where we don't need to talk about it being a hijacked organism.
It's purely a robotic miniature surveillance device.
Is that OK for us to use something that most people might not be aware of.
And why would we do that?
And one of the reasons for doing a lot of
biomorphic working robotics is this interesting two way street
which we learn so much more about how biology works when we
try to build artificial systems to imitate it and vice versa.
We then learn so much more about how physical robotic,
mechanical and electrical systems work when we try to replicate how the organisms work.
So robotics feeds our understanding of
biology which then feeds our understanding of robotics and
this kind of feedback loop goes all the way back to Grey Walter's tortoises in the 50's.
And he was a brain scientist and he built
the first autonomous mobile robots analog and they were like
flying robots and they displayed
a very lifelike behavior simply through you know phototropic behaviors.
And what inspired him was creating
physical modeling of the workings of neurons in the brain.
So there's one thing I do want to talk about
because it's always the doom and gloom issue as you and I are both aware.
Right. Is the idea that robots are taking all of our jobs.
Everywhere you look it seems like lately there's another article that's popping
up say robots are going to take all of our jobs by 2030.
You know 80% of the jobs in the U.S. are going to be automated,
farm workers are going to be out of their jobs in the next two years. Right.
Like it's always to this level of like
it's here and it's happening now and everything is going away and
time to go grab you know your pitchforks
and rise up against the robots before everything goes doom and gloom.
What are your thoughts on kind of
this portrayal in the media that you know robots are here to
take everything away from people and people are going to
be able to afford you know a life for their families.
Then there's this concept of know taxation on top of these robots?
The bonfire the robots issue.
It is so completely wrong.
Anybody who's developed robots has
a much greater appreciation of just how far behind that state we are.
I believe there are still fewer than two million industrial robots in the world.
Global total today.
And that's with China putting a huge amount of money into it
so that they now have this here become I think
the world's largest producer of robots as well as
the world's largest consumer of robots pushing Germany out of the top spot.
And yet the sum total two million.
OK. It's going to take quite a while for us to
spread sophisticated robotics technology around the globe.
And then I think the other thing is to look at certain industries.
And you mentioned farm workers.
If you were to mention that in an agricultural area
you would have everybody that owned a farm saying Can I have some
of those because I can't get enough workers.
And to look at this Labor Statistics,
almost every country in the world has
an aging population problem and it is worst in rural occupations.
So you pretty much going to have every farmer in
the world retiring in the next five to 10 years.
And at the same time we're shutting down
all of the cheap labor sources and seasonal labor sources that used to be.
So how are we going to prevent the world from starving and yet keep
food prices you know at the level that we expect them to be.
And you know we really do have to look at doubling food production over
the next generation not just keeping things as they are either.
So I see some huge areas where we actually have big problems.
We have global challenges that we need to do something about.
So whenever people talk about robots as a problem I stop and I go,
"Well what are the world's biggest problems?
And will robotics have a role to play in solving,
fixing or you know making those problems a little bit better.
And I think absolutely yes."
And if anyone is on the fence then focus on the ways that we need to solve
these problems and think about
the creative technologies that we have to put into play to fix global challenges.
And I think that's the most productive thing you can do with your time rather than
to spend it worried or in fear which first off I don't think is founded.
But second off if you got that energy there is a lot of good things that you can do.
So focus on those.
And yeah and not on that fear.
Well that's it for today,
Udacity's Explorer Human-Robot Interaction and Robotic Ethics.
Andra Keay. Thank you very much for your time, I appreciate it.
Thanks so much Mike.